joining us now Fox News legal analyst
Greg Jarrett former Florida attorney
general Pam Bondi Pam get your thoughts
first on the legal aspect of all this
important thing in any criminal
investigation as a prosecutor is to
treat all cases the same meaning if
something is similarly situated it needs
to be treated with uniformity clearly we
know that didn't happen here it's
already been established it didn't
happen here as you said president Trump
had the power to declassify Joe Biden
never did moreover the documents that
President Trump took went from the White
House the most secure place in the
country tomorrow Lago one of the most
secure places in the country guarded
constantly by Secret Service Joe Biden's
documents we have no idea where they
floated around for at least a year
before some went to the Biden Penn
center before some went to his house in
Delaware so you know the playbook's
already been written by Merrick Garland
if you want to treat them with
uniformity do the search warrant as you
said at all the Biden residences that's
important interview anyone who could
have touched those documents including
the child Chinese who wanted keys and
paid Millions to Hunter Biden Hunter
Biden as you said that was his residence
he could hit a garage door button and
access those documents so anyone who
could have come near those documents
needs to be interviewed the amount of
money Greg Jarrett we're talking about
is breathtaking Merrick Garland sat on
that news he had this November 2nd he
did not tell the American people that in
and of itself needs to be investigated
now we have not one not two but three
separate locations uh where these top
secret and classified documents were
were found but the money is the most
disturbing you know the the money to the
Penn Biden Center the overwhelming
majority of it came when Biden was there
he was being paid by the university the
university then had their professors uh
requests from Merrick garland that they
dropped an Espionage case with China he
dropped it I'm worried about everything
I'm reading here
yeah it looks like a quid pro quo
doesn't it or the equivalent of bribery
uh you know Joe Biden is is the new
Britney Spears Oops I did it again and
again and again
three different locations with
classified information in it you can
maybe rationalize it was in inadvertent
once uh maybe accidental twice three
times remember the criminal statute says
that the storing removal and storing of
classified information is a crime if
it's either intentional or Reckless this
now appears to be the definition of
recklessness under the criminal statute
and Joe Biden is at greater risk than
Donald Trump because Trump as a former
president
says he Declassified the documents
before he left office Joe Biden doesn't
have that defense available to him as
vice president and his defense today I
mean look I've been a lawyer for more
than 40 years I was a defense lawyer I
think I've heard every excuse in the
book today I heard a new one it's the uh
is it's the Corvette defense oh it's
okay to have classified dockets because
they're sitting next to my Corvette by
the way right garage look does that look
yeah there it is there's a picture right
there that's not long how many people
had how many people had access to that
that didn't have security clearance well
they won't give us the visitor logs and
so you know Joe Biden is at greater risk
than Donald Trump here
yeah the only and by the way as a bad
choice of Corvettes uh he can keep his
Stingray I'll take the new Z06 if I
could ever find one uh which you can all
right Greg Jarrett Thank you Pam Bondi
thank you hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else